ya hemos visto la ecuación en la
izquierda que relaciona el cambio en la
energía libre estándar delta g 0 al
potencial estándar de celda es 0 la
ecuación en la derecha es de
termodinámica y relaciona el cambio en
la energía libre estándar delta g 0 a la
constante de equilibrio acá podemos
igualar las para relacionar el potencial
estándar de celda a la constante de
equilibrio acá podemos igualar las para
relacionar el potencial estándar de
celda a la constante de equilibrio ya
que ambas son iguales a delta g 0
podemos decir que esto es igual a esto
ahora tenemos menos n efe
pero es igual a menos r de logaritmo
natural de la constante de equilibrio
que resolvamos para es 0 resolvamos para
el potencial estándar de celda para
hacer eso tenemos que dividir ambos
lados
entre menos ene efe obtenemos que
pero es igual a r de positivo sobre ene
efe
logaritmo natural de nuestra constante
de equilibrio luego vamos a resolver
para vamos a resolver para lo que es
igual a esto
si estamos a 25 grados celsius nuestra
temperatura en condiciones estándar para
las celdas de la que estamos hablando
que está en kelvin por lo que tenemos
que convertir grados celsius a kelvin y
para eso y para eso tienes que sumar 27
3.15 eso nos da 298 punto 15
kelvin y eso es lo que representa que la
temperatura absoluta en kelvin r es la
constante de gas
así que r es igual a 8.314 jules sobre
mol por kelvin
vamos a multiplicar eso por nuestra
temperatura absoluta nuestra temperatura
absoluta fue 298 punto 15
esto es 298 punto 15
kelvin todo esto se divide entre la
constante de faraday recuerda
efe es la constante de faraday ésta efe
de aquí la constante de faraday la cual
es 96
500 como blums sobre mol la carga de un
molde electrones esto nos da r t sobre f
y entonces sacamos la calculadora y
encontremos a lo que es esto igual
tenemos 8.314 por 29 8.15 y luego vamos
a dividir eso entre la constante de
faraday 96 1500 y entonces obtenemos
0.02 57 vamos a redondear eso punto 0
257 esto nos da 0.02 57 cuáles serían
las unidades bueno los cambios se
cancelarían aquí y veamos qué otra cosa
se cancelan los moles se cancelan y eso
nos da
y sobre cómics lo que por supuesto es
igual a volts
podemos volver a escribir nuestras
ecuaciones la que tenemos aquí arriba
vamos a sustituir para rt sobre f ahora
ahora tendremos tendremos el potencial
estándar de celda a cero es igual a 0.02
57 y eso son volts sobre
n recuerda que n es el número de moles
que son transferidos en tu reacción
redox y esto es por el logaritmo natural
de k nuestra constante de equilibrio
aquí esta es una forma de la ecuación
que relaciona el potencial estándar de
celda el potencial estándar de celda es
0 a la constante de equilibrio k podemos
escribir esto en una manera distinta lo
que podemos hacer es tomar s 0.025 70.0
257 y podemos multiplicar eso por el
logaritmo natural de 10 hagamos eso
tenemos 0.025 7 por el logaritmo natural
de
y eso nos da 0.05 92 obtenemos obtenemos
0.05 92 y la razón por la cual podemos
hacer esto es para escribir nuestra
ecuación en manera logarítmica aquí
arriba tenemos logaritmo natural aquí
arriba tenemos un logaritmo natural
ahora podemos escribir en forma
logarítmica ahora tenemos que el
potencial estándar de celda es 0 es
igual a ahora tenemos 0.05 92 volts
tenemos 0.05 92 volts nuevamente entre n
el número de moles de electrones
transferidos en nuestra reacción redox y
esta vez será por el logaritmo
el logaritmo de k
no el logaritmo natural sino el
logaritmo de k tomamos eso en cuenta en
nuestros cálculos
esta es sólo otra forma otra forma de la
misma ecuación relacionar el potencial
estándar de celda es 0 a la constante de
equilibrio k